Tonight, Taraji
P Henson's brutally honest
and emotional explanation
of Hollywood's
pay disparity is going viral.
CNN host Gayle King interviewed Henson
and the cast of The Color Purple.
It's a film from CNN's parent company,
Warner Brothers Discovery.
Now, King asked Henson
if she was thinking about quitting acting
I'm just tired
of working
so hard
being gracious at what I do.
Getting paid a fraction of the cost.
You get tired I hear people call.
You work a lot.
You have to the mayor.
Thank my friend.
Here to discuss this
with me
now is actress Yvette Nicole Brown.
Yvette,
that has really touched a nerve
in Hollywood.
She's been
Taraji has been nominated for an Oscar.
She's had multiple Emmys, Screen Actors
Guild Awards.
She's a household name.
It's surprising
to a lot of people
to see those tears and to hear her say
she's not being paid fairly.
Yeah, I
mean, the truth is, none of us are.
You know, the pay disparity
for black women,
period, is horrible
and it extends to Hollywood as well.
What broke
my heart about seeing it is
that Taraji is one of our treasures.
You know what I mean?
She's one of the ones
that has been
in the trenches for forever.
She should be paid what she's worth.
And the tears as she cried
they weren't just for her.
Because each of us
that are further along in our careers,
we're trying to leave the door
open for every black actresses
coming up behind us.
And the fear that she had
and the despair that she had was that
she is not making enough to be able
to tell them
what they should be asking for.
And she knows that if it's hard for her,
even harder for them.
So it just it broke my heart
and I think that's
why everybody's
been responding and chiming in
and making sure
she knows that we love her
and we support her
and that we're walking the same
path with her. Yeah.
I want to play a little bit
to what you were talking about here,
about what she
said in a separate interview.
Where's my race?
I am I
haven't seen a raise in my income,
says Proud Mary.
And almost had to walk away from Color
Purple. Because, you know what?
If I don't take a stand,
how am I making it easy for Fantasia?
And Danielle, Haley and Phylicia?
So why am I doing this
if it's all just for me?
What the why are you here?
Pay in any industry
in some ways is very subjective.
I can only imagine in Hollywood
it's even more so.
What do you think is the reason that,
you know, Hollywood
executives get away with paying
someone like Taraji less
and not giving her a raise movie
to movie role to roll?
Well, you know, systemic
racism is a part of
everything that happens in this nation.
But beyond that,
I think that there's this thing
where they pick people against each other
where the idea is, well,
you know,
if you don't want to do it,
we'll get somebody else to do it
and somebody won't maybe do.
And so they may take the lesser amount.
And we are we are lesser as a as a
as an industry,
because we don't get
to have the brilliance
of someone as Taraji
because they don't want to pay them
what they're worth.
And it's a fight that,
you know,
white actors don't have and white
female actors don't have.
And what she said
that really resonated with me,
Abby, was when she said
even if she fights
and gets what she needs
for this particular film,
she has to start all over again.
The next time she gets a film
because you don't get to walk in.
Well, I negotiated this, this and this.
And I am Taraji
P Henson, and I have this Oscar
nomination, whatever.
Now it's like you starting over
and you just walked in and, well,
you know, we're going to give you
this $5 in a volunteer.
It's the same for all of us.
And it's infuriating and exhausting.
One of the factors here,
the Color Purple,
she just said in that clip,
she almost walked away from that film.
That's a film
that is near
and dear
to the heart of Oprah
Winfrey is a part of that process.
Does it surprise you to hear that
even on a film like that,
where there is a prominent
black woman as a part of the process
of making it,
that she could still feel
that she was underpaid?
Taraji, we're showing here,
posted a photo of Oprah thanking her
for supporting her throughout her career.
But what do you make of that event?
Well well,
we don't know
if if Oprah had anything
to do with the pay situation.
So we can't say
that she was warring against
anything that Oprah did in particular.
So I want to make sure I say that
I think a lot of times
it comes from business affairs.
You talk to your friends,
we're going to do this movie
or this TV show together.
And then by the time
it gets to the lawyers
negotiating everything
that you and your friend decided
or you discussed
gets torn down by the legal process.
So sometimes it's it's
the people in the legal department.
Like we're not giving it to a trailer.
Wait a minute. You know?
And so
we never know where the breakdown is,
but we know that the breakdown
happens every time.
This is not an isolated incident.
Her tears are not just her tears.
We all have cried then.
We all are fighting to make it better.
And again,
it's not even just
entertainment industry.
You can talk to any system
that's working in any industry.
And we have to always fight harder.
It's just the way it is.
And we're tired of it
being that's just the way it is.
You know, even someone who it seems
almost everybody knows who she is
still fighting these battles.
Yvette, Nicole Brown,
thank you so much for joining us on this.
Thank you for having me.